bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro deux tim hague
alors vous le savez à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout est mis
en oeuvre pour booster le développement
économique du territoire prêts d'honneur
futur incubateurs pépinières
d'entreprises concours les solutions ne
manquent pas pour accompagner ceux qui
ont envie d'entreprendre et parmi ces
entrepreneurs des femmes professions
libérales artisanes directrice générale
elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses à
se lancer dans le monde de
l'entrepreneuriat par qui sont elles
pour vous nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de ces saint-quentinoise qui
font bouger les lignes
c'est parti
commençons par quelques chiffres
histoire de cerner un peu mieux la
problématique de l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin
il faut savoir que près de 48 % de la
population active et féminine
or selon une étude de l'insee publiée en
en france seulement un tiers des
indépendants et des chefs d'entreprises
sont des femmes elles représentent 40 %
des auto-entrepreneurs 25% des gérant de
sarl et 17% hors sarl
en résumé près de la moitié de la
population active est composée de femmes
mais elles ont encore beaucoup de mal à
franchir le pas du monde de
l'entrepreneuriat et lorsqu'elles le
font elles se retrouvent très souvent à
la tête deux petites entreprises
par ailleurs cette étude nous montre que
majoritairement elles ont tendance à
s'orienter vers des secteurs
traditionnellement 10 féminin mais
certaines sortent des sentiers battus
comme florence bourreau et delphine oui
la première dirige la carrosserie du
plateau et la seconde à monter
l'entreprise de plomberie à quoi
procéder avec son père
il s'agit là de deux domaines
d'activités où les femmes sont encore
très minoritaires
c'est en 1999 que florence bourreau
acquiert la carrosserie du plateau à
guyancourt
c'est une passion j'aime bien j'aime
bien bricoler chez moi je fait toucher
du parquet je fais de la peinture je
fais du carrelage donc ça ça me dérange
pas du tout la mécanique la carrosserie
ce pas très très compliqué pour
commander des mecs il faut avoir un
certain caractère parce que surtout moi
j'en ai un cas une certaine expérience
il est quand même carrossier depuis à
mon avis plus de trente ans donc dirigé
par une femme c'est pas toujours facile
je lève tout confort la voix premier
puis ça passe
l'entrepreneuse ne compte pas ses heures
et met volontiers la main à la pâte
trois salariés 380 mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires annuel pour un
résultat net de 50000 euros en quelques
années
florence a fait de son garage une
affaire qui roule et c'est bien parti
pour durer
l'entrepreneuse est d'ailleurs à la
recherche d'un carrossier ou d'un
peintre noter qu'il s'agit là d'une
création de poste
c'est une activité effectivement qui
tourne à plein régime on a beaucoup d'un
vraiment assurances
on a aussi on est assez connue sur lui
en cours on a des grands groupes comme
bouygues qui travaillent avec nous après
des études de comptabilité quelques
années de salariat delphine wii est
aujourd'hui à la tête de la société aqua
procédé hébergés aux promos paul à
montigny le bretonneux dacquois procédé
est une société spécialisée dans le
chauffage le traitement d'eau et les
certificats d'économie d'énergie
c'est vrai que le bâtiment
c'est souvent les hommes qui sont dans
ce domaine d'activité la d'être une
femme pour moi c'est plus un avantage ça
nous permet de les démarquer
les autres suivi tout au long de son
projet par la maison de l'entreprise
delphi louis a également bénéficié d'un
prêt d'honneur initiative saint quentin
en yvelines le réseau initiative qui est
un réseau national accorde trois types
de prêts des prêts pour la création pour
le développement et pour la transmission
d'entreprise la plateforme de 50 hommes
accordent régulièrement au moins trois
ou quatre par mois près des créateurs
d'entreprise
cette jeune créatrice séduit le comité
de sélection et elle a bénéficié de ce
prêt d'honneur 12000 euros pour la
création de son entreprise
sachant que nous prêts d'honneur sont
pour la création dans une fourchette de
5 à 25 mille euros il nous a permis de
pouvoir financer un fonds de roulement
c'est difficile de financer ça par les
banques donc ça a été quand même à réel
en soutien depuis sa création en juillet
2015 la société a réalisé un chiffre
d'affaires de 110 mille euros hors taxes
delphine ou espère bien accroître encore
l'activité et embaucher de nouveaux
salariés
l'entrepreneuse s'est fixé un objectif
quadruplé son chiffre d'affaires dans
les trois ou quatre prochaines années
les entrepreneurs re les entrepreneuses
ou bien encore les chefs d'entreprise
sont en général plus jeunes et mieux
formés que leurs homologues masculins
d'après le baromètre femmes et création
d'entreprise de 2012 58% sont diplômés
de l'enseignement supérieur contre 47 %
chez les hommes si elles ont le goût
d'entreprendre et une volonté
d'indépendance
elle exprime aussi clairement le besoin
de s'épanouir sur le plan personnel
c'est le cas de perrine étiez cet élan
courtoise a choisi de laisser de côté un
métier qui ne lui plaisait pas à 100%
pour vivre pleinement sa passion de la
mode
après des études de commerce et un
parcours professionnel dans la vente
perrine décide de tout plaquer début
2015 pour vivre sa passion et un moment
donné ou où l'épanouissement il n'est
pas il n'est pas complet et on sait
qu'il nous manque quelque chose et un
moment donné je me suis dit que gagner
de l'argent c'était hyper bien mais
gagner de l'argent pour être pas que
j'ai pas malheureuse ce n'est pas le cas
mais pas épanouie à 100%
bah ça vaut pas le coup et j'ai tout
lâché j'ai monté ma société
l'entrepreneuse élan courtoise coup
depuis tout petit
dans son atelier elle crée des
accessoires des vêtements sur mesure et
des robes de mariée lorsque nous l'avons
rencontré
perrine était en pleine préparation du
salon du mariage au cours duquel elle
présentera 15 modèles de robes grâce à
l'événement elle espère donner un coup
d'accélérateur à sa société
si le succès est au rendez vous elle
envisage de trouver un local plus grand
et pourquoi pas d'embaucher un ou deux
salariés
pour vivre sa passion et surtout vivre
de sa passion
il ne faut pas compter ses heures mais
également être ultra polyvalent je fais
tout de la vaisselle jusqu'au rangement
et puis à l'administratif la cuisine
bien sûr depuis 2012 sandrine girard est
à la tête de 3g une société de vente de
plats cuisinés
récemment elle s'est installée à
maurepas après avoir démarré son
aventure entrepreneuriale dans son
ancienne société à saint-ouen tu me suis
aperçu qu'en fait il y avait un manque
midi pour les gens qui cherchaient à
déjeuner plutôt traditionnelle pour
éviter les sandwichs et choses comme ça
quand j'ai un peu plus équilibré donc du
coup j'ai commencé à servir
des plats le midi dans la société dans
laquelle je travaillais donc au
personnel de la société et ça a bien
fonctionné ça a bien plus sain plus de
l'ampleur du coup j'ai lâché mon travail
et j'ai ouvert la boutique de 8 mars de
cette année
les femmes sont moins avide de pouvoir
que les hommes ce n'est pas moi qui le
dit mais une étude conduite par kpmg
dont les résultats ont été publiés en
juin 2015
l' enquête d'opinion menée auprès de 600
chefs d'entreprise révèle que 25 % des
femmes interrogées affirment avoir saisi
une opportunité contre 18 % des hommes
cette appétence moindre pour les postes
dirigeants n'empêche pas les femmes
d'accéder aux plus hautes fonctions
jugez plutôt titulaire d'un bts
d'opticien end une licence d'optique
d'un billet et d'un master obtenu à hec
delphine ansquer devient en 2011
directrice générale de la filiale
rodenstock france à montigny le
bretonneux une société qui produit et
commercialise des verts et des montures
de lunettes qui est un camp france
rodenstock réalise un chiffre d'affaires
d'environ 20 à 30 millions d'euros
avec sa nomination des finances pierre
devient la première femme directrice
d'une filiale du groupe doté d'un
caractère affirmé
elle a sa petite idée quant aux raisons
qui font qu'il y ait moins de femmes que
d'hommes à des postes comme le sien nous
sommes entourés par par des hommes au
niveau effectivement managériale et
parfois nous n'osons pas je crois que ça
c'est la première chose et la deuxième
chose et notre vie de famille il n'est
pas facile d'avoir à la fois un poste
directrice générale et une vie de
famille avec des enfants et j'ai pu
prendre ce poste parce que j'avais une
grande fille 1 qui avait
17 ans lorsque j'ai pris le poste et là
j'ai pu effectivement prendre ce poste
des femmes inventive qui vivent leur
passion et qui sortent des sentiers
battus lorsqu'on les interroge sur leurs
motivations
étrangement très peu d'entre elles
évoquent spontanément le désir d'être
son propre patron ou de diriger une
équipe
entreprendre est un vrai challenge et
pour le réussir les femmes chefs
d'entreprise se serre les coudes et
s'organisent en réseaux
les clubs de dirigeants d'entreprises
font aujourd'hui partie des outils
incontournables pour ceux qui souhaitent
réussir dans les affaires
entrepreneuriat au féminin et créactive
sont deux réseaux destinés aux
entrepreneuse qui se lance ou bien celle
plus aguerris à la recherche de conseils
ou de nouveaux contacts
l'objectif en fait est d'aider ces
femmes en leur apportant de
l'information du partage de compétences
entre membres on va pouvoir partager nos
savoir-faire nos expériences
on s'aperçoit la plupart du temps c'est
que le premier frein aux femmes chefs
d'entreprise ce sont les femmes
elles-mêmes et qu'elle donc beaucoup
moins présent donc notre objectif plutôt
de pouvoir les aider les conseiller et
leur montrer que d'autres ont tenté
l'aventuré on réussit pleinement et
largement de ces chefs d'entreprise se
retrouvent régulièrement à l'occasion de
déjeuner de réunion ou d'activités
ludiques des moments de partage comme
dans beaucoup d'autres réseaux
finalement alors pourquoi des clubs
féminins y at il tant de problématiques
spécifiques aux femmes
écoutez ses membres de créer active ça
ne devrait pas mais concrètement je
pense qu'on n'est pas encore à l'égalité
complète sur la gestion des enfants et
les activités annexes donc il ya
effectivement une manière différente de
travailler je pense sur les femmes et
notamment les femmes on en est quand on
travaille chez soi comment faire pour
exister à l'appel de la machine à laver
pour faire garder les enfants pour
s'organiser
toutes ces questions qu'on a au début
quand on veut se lancer
eh bien on peut les partager avec
d'autres femmes d'autres femmes sont
passés par ces étapes là d'autre part on
se retrouve en tant qu'entrepreneur
souvent dans une jungle encore
essentiellement masculine il faut faire
doublement ses preuves
être reconnu être acceptée
voilà donc je pense qu'entre femmes il
ya beaucoup d'entre aide en général ya
beaucoup de bienveillance
il ya beaucoup de solidarité et on se
comprend
le doute n'est plus permis à saint
quentin en yvelines le développement
économique passe par l'entrepreneuriat
au féminin
alors mesdames n'hésitez plus
lancez-vous
on est encore trop sous l'image de la
femme qui doit être la maman qui doit
aller chercher ses enfants à la crèche à
l'école etc qui doit être une bonne mère
de famille une bonne mère de famille
c'est quoi c'est aussi montrer l'exemple
à ses enfants et à tous les gens qui
peuvent vous suivre vos amis les gens
qui trouvent que c'est admirable ce que
vous faites et être un exemple c'est
être heureux et trouver des sources de
bonheur et si cette source de bonheur
c'est l'entrepreneuriat lancez-vous
si vous êtes passionnés comme moi par là
par la cuisine n'hésitez pas c'est une
aventure qui est à vivre même si au
départ c'est compliqué je pense que on a
tout à gagner à toutes les femmes qui
voudraient entreprendre dans le domaine
du bâtiment
il faut persévérer car vous avez votre
place au sein de ce domaine
les femmes sont aussi sinon plus
créatrice est capable que les hommes
pour monter leur entreprise pour
prospecter pour séduire des clients donc
lancé vous c'est le moment à toutes les
structures tous les statuts sont
possibles à vous tuer vous êtes à peu
près 30% de fer entrepreneurs le rêve
c'est que vous puissiez devenir secondes
pour son puisque toutes et tous devaient
pouvait avait le droit de créer une
entreprise balancer vous ne sais pas il
ya plein de choses à faire il faut il
faut il faut tenter l'expérience
essayez pas mesdames une seule chose aux
écarts vous avez les compétences
je crois qu'il ya quelque part à saint
quentin en yvelines comme ailleurs
beaucoup de femmes qui ont d'énormes
qualités qui ont des très bons projets
mais qui hésitent parfois à se lancer
parce qu'il peut y avoir un réflexe
d'autocensure plus que chez les hommes
donc nous ici bien sûr on essaie de les
accompagner il y à des structures aussi
sur ce territoire qui essayent de
favoriser aussi l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin
moi ce que j'ai envie de dire un peu au
saint-quentinoise aux femmes de 50 à ces
vraiment medad n'hésitez pas à vous
lancer vous avez tout ce qu'il faut pour
réussir ici sur ce territoire est
souvent d'ailleurs vous réussissez mieux
que les hommes donc vraiment alesi à
l'isie a promis aux pâles comme ailleurs
on sera très heureux de vous accueillir
voilà ce qui m'agace c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau
roux d'ici là portez vous bien ciao bye